foreign
live I'm your host Ian hardins here on
behalf of the fine folks over at Pro
Football Focus happy week 10 halfway
through the season so far how quickly
time flies let's try to get those
rosters ready to go for the upcoming
fantasy playoffs before we gotta do that
guys I gotta share with you quite
possibly the single worst fantasy
football trade I have ever seen it
wasn't in one of my leagues but came
back to my mind you know Darren Waller
unfortunately has hit the injured
reserve list with a hamstring injury we
also have Hunter Renfro there with no
Bleak and the Waller news specifically
two weeks ago I was doing my Friday
research on injuries and a lot of these
West Coast teams take longer than the
east coast and the Midwest teams to
actually get their injury reports in so
I just kept researching stuff on Darren
Waller seeing if he was going to be
questionable game time decision whatever
and I came across a tweet from our poor
guy Drew Banks and Drew is actually
asking Twitter which plenty of people do
but plenty of people don't ask him this
objectively dumb of a trade question do
I take a big swing and trade Joe Mixon
for Darren Waller now I don't want to be
hindsight doctor here because obviously
mixing coming off a five touchdown
performance and Darren Waller just got
injured but guys this was two weeks ago
during Waller was already injured Joe
Mixon have won the largest workloads in
all of football I saw the Tweet
scrolling the first time I didn't say
anything five minutes later I you know
look up another thing on jerem Waller
and I saw the uh the Tweet again this
guy didn't follow me he didn't ask me
for my advice I felt obligated as a
American citizen as someone that I like
to think is a good person to reach out
to Drew and tell him straight up that no
do not do this for a love of God Drew
please do not make that trade
he made the trade God this guy traded
Joe freaking Mixon for Darren Waller
straight up and to make matters worse is
look this isn't a situation where he
didn't have a tight end he already had
TJ Hawkinson on the squad obviously he's
now doing great things with the Vikings
okay you couldn't have predicted that
but let's face it the difference between
Waller and Hawkinson awfully minuscule
and to make that trade for Joe Mixon
like my God I I wish I was in more
leagues uh with Drew but hey credit to
the guy he's you know taking on the chin
still responding to some you know kind
of angry people and dimensions getting
after it you know hopefully he will be
able to take that team to the playoffs
and get the championship because guess
what if Drew manages to win making this
trade I think he should be getting maybe
not manager of the year we can't quite
look past that but come back over the
years something like that we will see
what happens as Drew had to say at the
end of the stream nobody wins a ship not
taking risk let's try to mitigate those
risks a little bit if we can best of
luck to Drew and now Darren Waller on
the squad here moving forward but enough
of that guys welcome to be our Fantasy
Live presented by State Farm we have a
fantastic show for you guys on the dog
today I want to go through players that
you need to trade for right now and no
I'm not going to list the top 10 players
at every position and say look how good
all these guys have been go ski you know
go buy high on all these players I'm
going to say some players that have been
good this year but more than anything I
tried to pick eight players that I think
are realistic trade targets where you're
not going to have to sell the best
players that hopefully have you in a
position to get to the playoffs in the
first place hopefully you know
accumulate some other assets and go get
players that I have reason to believe
haven't even played their best football
of the season yet so we're going to
start things off with Arizona Cardinals
running back James Connor
foreign
there it is with Connor guys I know it
hasn't been a good first half of the
season because guess what he got hurt
and I understand you go back and look
throughout Conor's career he has gotten
hurt a good amount but have we learned
nothing from trying to predict these
running back injuries and we don't need
to go that far back in time to remember
everyone talking about Christian
McCaffrey getting hurt and how Jonathan
Taylor was the most sure thing in the
NFL so yes those early season injuries
sucked for for James Connor he is
healthy now though everyone and the
Cardinals appreciate that and
accordingly are back to giving him his
near every down rule this season James
Connor has played four non-injure games
and in those contests he's had 15 16 18
and 12 touches and on those also
contests 60 to 70 snaps each and every
time so why hasn't James Connor been
putting up big numbers in those games it
has to do with his lack of goal line
opportunities and a Cardinals offense
that hasn't been fantastic I mean last
year only Jonathan Taylor had more
carries inside the five yard line than
James Connor this year Connor only has
three so the reason why I am hopeful
that things could be turning around for
this offense healthy versions of Rondo
Moore and DeAndre Hopkins have already
started to help this offense have to
keep their foot on the gas a little bit
more in the passing game and do a good
job moving the ball up and down the
field I mean over the past three weeks
they have gotten some help from some
defensive touchdowns but this is an
offense averaging 29.3 points per game
over these past three weeks and more
importantly like we saw with the early
season lions like we saw at the early
season Seahawks before they fixed their
defense a little bit this Cardinals
defense sucks I mean they brought in JJ
Watt Chandler Jones you can I know they
got red Chandler but you can talk about
Byron Murphy Buddha Baker a lot of good
guys in this defense they just haven't
been able to pull it off this year 31st
ranked in scoring so we have an offense
that does move with a quick Pace they
now have healthy options to make us
believe that okay they should be putting
up points at a little bit higher rate
than they have in the past and we
finally have a healthy James Conner so I
really think that Conor moving forward
is someone that has the worst workload
of a top 15 player again if we just went
off those touches and snap raids covered
up the names and you know you knew
nothing about the situation otherwise
we'd be looking at James Connor a lot
like we would someone like Damien Pierce
someone like potentially Kenneth Walker
with a little bit less meat on the bone
in terms of Rush attempts again not the
talent involved just in terms of the
workload involved and that's why we have
the opportunity to buy fairly low on
James Connor in the first place so
really confident that we are going to be
seeing him getting those goal line
carries because guess what Kyla Murray
he doesn't QB sneak you know using the
fancy Dancy PFF back back door tools
only one career quarterback Snake for
Cutler because he's not a very big guy
let's face it how do I know it's only
because of Kyler because Colt McCoy and
Chris drevler five combined QB sneaks in
their limited action without kylo in the
picture so James Connor the primary
touchdown score of an offense with a lot
of room to go up here moving forward
don't be afraid to buy low on what has
the potential to be one of the last few
remaining Workhorse running backs in the
NFL ahead of the second half
appreciate the chat here we go everyone
all right stop asking questions it's
pre-recorded it's not pre-recorded jjyd
come on man I'm right here 506 Eastern
in the great Cincinnati Ohio football
capital of the world some might say uh
from Jesse Stewart do I start DJ Moore
tonight with rain in the forecast so the
big problem isn't so much the rain and
fantasy football I'm not overly worried
about the rain it's more so the wind and
they are projecting gusts of 20 to 30
miles per hour so DJ Moore we're going
to talk about him in a little bit I'm
optimistic that he's going to have
better days to come because of the
volume in this offense without CMC and
Robbie and just the fact that DJ Moore
is really freaking good at football but
as after I adjust my uh ranks you know
from just non-weather and do stuff I had
DJ more wide receiver 20. I'm gonna be
dropping him to probably about wide
receiver 30 wide receiver 31 so guys
like Judy Josh Palmer Devonte Smith
Brandon I would be starting them ahead
of DJ more don't go crazy like DJ Moore
versus Paris Campbell or something like
that okay I'll still take DJ Moore there
but just keep in mind that wind in such
a rainy environment and an offense that
as we know not exactly the highest floor
in the first place yes if you do have a
close substitute I would make it from DJ
Moore and Kyle Pitts alike from atlamola
traded Josh Jacobs for waddle running
backs are Eckler and CPAP wide receivers
are CD waddle and Hopkins good or bad
trade yeah I think this is fine I mean I
actually had a couple leagues myself
with Hopkins where when you get him off
the bench you know after those first six
weeks of the year you know seven
whatever it was with the bye week by
weeks later but anyway when you get
Hopkins Off the Bench as we've seen
you're adding a wide receiver one two
the squad that you didn't have already
so clearly you know you needed to go
ahead and just try to spruce up even
more adding Jalen waddle a legit top 10
wide receiver too that makes a lot of
sense so Josh Jacobs I don't see him
particularly falling off in his own
right but you know Jacobs first waddle
straight up the rest of the season I
would take Jalen waddle so good job by
you my friend gonna take us right into
our second player that I just think you
should be trying to buy it's not going
to be cheap but remind Dre Stevenson go
get him
with remandre look it's one of these
things where I think we have a chance
because of the bye week because JJ
Taylor was weirdly involved last week
and because Damien Harris did come back
the week before and get 10 plus carries
I'm not sure people realize just how
fancy friendly ramondre Stevenson's role
is and I get it he's not going to be
cheap to acquire but guys expected PPR
points and all that means is their
workload no putting aside how good they
are how many points we expect them to
score based on the touches that they
were given in the situations that they
were in and with that guys the rb7 on
the season hopefully Joe Mixon Eckler
Barkley Kamara Derrick Henry and
Christian McCaffrey have had more
fantasy friendly workloads than armandre
Stevenson you just hear that list again
Mixon Eckler Barkley Kamara Henry
Christian McCaffrey and ramondre
Stevenson those are your most fantasy
friendly running backs in the NFL so no
I don't think ramandre is going to be
having this 90 snap rate every single
week but guess what he doesn't need to
he has the fantasy friendly targets that
we're looking for in full are scoring
over just about anything else so with
romander in the pass game this year he's
been fantastic I mean one of only six
running backs with at least 35 catches
one of only seven over 225 receiving
yards PFF receiving grade only Christian
McCaffrey has been better this season so
Mac Jones and bayley zappy alike not
exactly known for you know consistently
pushing the ball downfield like a Jameis
Winston of the world so I think ramandre
in this offense even if it's not scoring
quite at the rate that we would like to
he's the clear-cut lead back even in
that game Damien and JJ Taylor were
involved Stevenson still easily leading
the way on the ground and more important
than anything we have the pass down work
which has really been the thing
producing these high-end Patriots
running backs over the years even going
back to like 2012 guys Shane Vereen and
James White those are the two top 10
fantasy running backs the Patriots have
produced even Damien Harris and
LeGarrette Blount they couldn't even
rank higher than 15th despite scoring
all those touchdowns because full PPR
scoring is kind of ridiculous and
outdated in my opinion but guess what
it's a game we play so to take advantage
of one of the most fantasy friendly
running backs in the NFL in ramondre
Stevenson
from the chat at respect to you trade
for Tua again it's always going to
depend what you have to give up here by
one point with Tua is he doesn't give
you too much of a floor with the rushing
I mean he even going back to Alabama has
never had even 50 rushing yards in a
single game during his career and look
I've watched the offense over the past
two weeks fantastic stuff can we take a
small step back here like they played
the Lions and the Bears over the past
two weeks the week before that Tua
couldn't stop throwing dropped
interceptions against the Steelers on
Sunday Night Football so I think I think
the offense is awesome Tyree kill you
know they're not going to give anyone
other than QB and MVP but my goodness if
any wide receiver out there deserved it
very well could be Tyreek Hill I'm very
optimistic that Tua is going to continue
being really good that said how big is
the difference between him and some
wafer wire options that you might be
able to get like a cousins or a car in
the right matchup Trevor Lawrence Justin
Fields I wouldn't go too far out of my
way to trade for two because I still
don't think he's quite in that Josh
Allen Jalen hurts a true cheat code
level of course quarterback play
from at spider MVP Donovan Mitchell baby
do I trade Swift and Goddard for Pollard
Schultz and JuJu I think in this trade
it's reasonable enough that I probably
would make that move yeah Schultz with
that Prescott under Center has really
been a godsend ever since he's gotten
him back and I know he's been playing
through the knee injury as well but I do
think Goddard is for sure a better real
life tight end than Dalton Schultz but
we saw it last year Dak is willing to
feed Schultz with Reckless abandon and
he should be healthier coming off that
PCO issue having that bye week to get
right so I don't think Goddard and
Schultz is as big of a drop off as some
uh might be thinking and from that point
you're trading DeAndre Swift to said
himself that he doesn't know if he's
going to be ever back to 100 at any
point in the season you're getting
someone in Tony Pollard who is a
continued Zeke injury away from being
what the kids might call that League
winning asset and then my Juju Smith
Schuster I mean hey you know I was
talking before the show a little extra
segment we'll have about players I was
wrong on like hand up I didn't think
that Juju in the year 2022 was going to
be able to be this year's Cooper cup as
everyone was talking about and no he's
not on Pace to have the most freaking
fantasy points in NFL history uh from a
wide receiver but really has become the
clear-cut number one wide receiver for
that Chiefs offense so I do think
trading Swift and God are for Pollard
Schultz and JuJu is a good move to make
all right guys I want to talk about
another tight end not Dalton Schultz
actually won for your Cleveland Browns
David najoku
with najoku the reason why I think you
need to go trade him is because once
again his value of his value really
hasn't been lower in quite some time now
I know the injury has to do with that
he's not even necessarily likely to play
this week specifically but we are
looking ahead and boy is it going to
start looking good on offense for this
Browns wants to get the Sean Watson back
so go ahead think whatever you want
about that I'm not asking for a moral
opinion on the Joker or Watson but it's
going to be an objectively better
offense with the Sean Watson under
Center in place of Jacoby Brissette and
once we add that into the equation now
all of a sudden we have the number two
pass game option in Cleveland being Dave
in the Joker with a couple extra weeks
to get healthy and then we're starting
to look back at the guy who was honestly
starting to emerge as a locked in top
five tight end even before having Watson
under Center so they've been ajoku this
season man still just a 26 year old
talent that everyone's been kind of
waiting on to break out over the years
and that's exactly what he was doing
before he had this injury 50 plus yards
in five straight games five plus
reception and all but one of those Titan
8 on the season ahead of guys like Pat
Friedman and Gerald Everett I mean
George Kittle guys only 0.4 more PPR
points per game than Dave and the Joker
this year I'm guessing it cost you a lot
more to go out there and get George
Kittle than David najoku and honestly if
Watson comes back and looks like the
Deshawn Watson that we saw in Houston
it's not inexplicable to think that Dave
and the Joker could be ranked ahead of
guys like George Kittle by the time we
were getting into week 11 and 12. so
honestly we're gonna have Watson back
there against Houston in week 13 after
that winnable enough matchups Bengals
Ravens Saints in Washington I'm not
saying those are complete layouts by
anything but Dave najoku with the talent
and an offense that still is somehow a
top 10 scoring offense without Watson I
think the joke is going to be getting
healthy at the right time he should be
on your fantasy Squad there's not gonna
you're not gonna need more than one hand
to rank the number of tight ends you'd
rather have over Dave najoku for the
fantasy playoffs from J money in our
chat should I trade DJ Moore for Keenan
Allen I don't think so man like who the
heck knows what's going on with a Keenan
Allen's hamstring I get my notification
every single day same day is not
practicing Brandon Staley tells us he's
day to day but I don't know man I don't
want to call the guy a silent quitter or
anything like that but it just we
haven't seen him since week one and with
these somewhat elderly receivers I just
don't see it there for Keenan Allen so
DJ Moore the big alert for him isn't
just the fact that he's really good at
football we did find that out that is
still true with these two big
performances over the past three weeks
but losing McCaffrey losing Robbie
Anderson it just really does give him a
higher volume floor than what he was
dealing with over the past two years so
I think DJ more I mean you could argue
that his total targets next to Keenan
Allen even if both were healthy probably
higher and I think just the fact that
Keenan we have no feel for his health I
would take DJ more
from at Rich J Dawson should I trade a
Pollard for Connor I do think that's
reasonable guys Ezekiel Elliott is
expected to come back this week and as
much as we love Tony Pollard he's
someone that's going to continue to play
behind Zeke I mean heck we saw when Zeke
was out the Cowboys end up only giving
Pollard 15 touches in that game now he's
number one the NFL and yards for Kerry
so it worked out for him just fine in
that but Tony Pollard is still someone
that's pretty hard to flex more weeks
than not I do think James Connor who
let's not forget all the way back guys
so long ago in the year 2021
legitimately was a top eight PPR running
back so still has that role the
Cardinals have 21 million reasons why
James Collins should continue to be in
that role who do I think is the better
player if I was starting a team
absolutely Tony Pollard but that's not
what's going on here two good players
and one of them I believe will have a
much more fantasy friendly workload
Batman is James Connor let's talk some
wide receivers though guys I want to
talk about one man that made quite a bit
of money in free agency and has been
doing good over the past few weeks hot
start the season I I think the best is
still yet to come from the Jacksonville
Jaguars Christian Kirk
so if you guys caught the stream last
week we went over some strength of
schedule stuff you know from basically
week nine up until the fantasy playoffs
get going nice little five-week stretch
and the number one offense in terms of
the easiest strength to schedule for
their wide receivers the Jacksonville
Jaguars so they're actually not going to
face a defense ranked better than 27th
in PPR points per game allowed to wide
receivers until the fantasy playoffs go
ahead and arise and honestly with
Christian Kirk even once we start
getting some of these tougher opponents
he has a sort of volume friendly role
that I don't think it's going to be too
much of a problem so you know we like to
make fun of coaches a lot when they say
things that don't necessarily happen and
yeah it's fun to go ahead and you know
get our jobs in there but do we expect
coaches to give away their game plans in
the media absolutely not so it's one of
those things where we have fun on
Twitter but I don't blame the guys shout
out Doug Peterson for not lying to all
of us out there and getting Christian
Kirk more involved when he said he was
going to I mean you look back at it
before week six Peterson says
specifically Christian Kirk needs to be
up there 9 10 11 seven targets possibly
and since then 5 10 7 and 9 targets with
two Rush attempts for good measure
thrown in there as well so Christian
Kirk has a higher percentage of his
team's targets and air yards than guys
like Jalen waddle like T Higgins and
like Devonte Smith and I get it those
are number two receivers in their own
offense but those are the types of guys
that honestly Christian Kirk has been
performing with and I don't think people
are giving him enough credit for doing
that similar to what we're talking about
ramandre Stevenson I still think some of
the stuff you know from the past is just
clouding exactly how good Kirk has been
on the field this year so overall I mean
he's the wide receiver 19 in PPR points
per game tied with Chris olave and CD
lamb so I guess that's my big thing here
like Christian Kirk CD lamb Chris olave
I think it's pretty reasonable to say
that Christian Kirk would be the guy
that he can get for the cheapest out of
that group and they're averaging the
same exact amount of PPR points per game
this season and looking at those guys
hey there's no wide receiver coming back
in Jacksonville like Jarvis could in New
Orleans or like maybe in certain OB Jay
could sign in Dallas I think the best
could be still to come here for
Christian Kirk because honestly Trevor
Lawrence hasn't been very good this year
he was fantastic in week two and week
three and in week nine so I'm hoping
that this most recent effort where he
was pff's second highest grade
quarterback last week is a side of more
things to come if it is we're looking at
a guy that could honestly be in the top
10 in full PPR discussions sooner rather
than later so Christian Kirk he's
already been a top 20 wide receiver this
year on a pretty mediocre Jaguars
offense overall I think we have seen
enough good from Trevor Lawrence from
Doug Peterson to think there's a higher
ceiling for this passing game in general
and if they are going to find that
higher ceiling they're Undisputed number
one target Christian Kirk is going to be
a primary beneficiary
from at the Pinot guy just got Tyrique
for Evans Antonio Gibson and moster
didn't he give up too much absolutely
not my friend a couple weeks ago here on
BR Fantasy Live I had to go through some
trade tips and one of my main things was
try to make sure you're coming away with
the best player in the deal and boy did
you ever get in Tyrique there so Antonio
Gibson and most are like you can talk
about their potential to have these
three down roles but unfortunately Brian
Robinson is out there every bit as much
as Gibson I know JJ mckissick is out for
the moment but not necessarily ruled out
for the year and with mostert he just
got outworked by Jeff Wilson last week
so that could be a sign that he's even
going to be unusable moving up so at
that point is Tyreek and Mike Evans and
you picked the right one my friend at
tck podcast LeBron washed man what are
you doing here this is fantasy football
bro and don't be calling LeBron watch
can we just give the man a break how
like think about what we're going to be
doing when we're that age I don't know
man LeBron James going out there as a
Cleveland Cavalier fan man he got to
stop ringing I'm never gonna take that
slander so go ahead go get an NBA chat
or or hang out you know we can help the
fantasy Squad as well all right guys I
got another wide receiver I've kind of
spoiled it already but hey he's a good
one you should get him on the squad
you're moving forward Panthers wide
receiver one DJ Moore
three things that go in the DJ more
expecting him to still be good we saw
two booms in the last three weeks he is
still good at football and the thing
that I came around and said after the
nice week seven before the Falcons game
was we really did have a big thing
change for DJ more it wasn't like he
just randomly overnight had a big game
we took out Christian McCaffrey and
Robbie Anderson and we can laugh about
Robbie Anderson all we want if you go
back and look at 2020 2021 in this
offense Robbie was every bit as involved
as DJ heck the guy out targeted DJ more
in the year 2020 still a lot of those
lingering coaches even though I know
Matt rules out of the pictures so you
take out Robbie and okay Terence
Marshall has come in and done some good
things but the Panthers said it
themselves at the trade deadline they
viewed DJ Moore as a building block of
this team and Dave Accord lay acted like
it over these past three weeks so yeah I
understand there was a dud last week no
receiver is going to be awesome every
single time out there the volume should
be there we've still seen the examples
of him being able to have these blow up
games in the year to 2022 and guys the
schedule down the stretch looks juicy
week 15 they get the Steelers dead last
ranked defense and PPR points per game
allowed to the position in week 16 they
get the lines so I honestly if you are a
DJ more manager right now we talked
about the risks with trying to play him
this week you know in that rainy and
windy setting that we're getting in
Charlotte here on Thursday night if DJ
Moore does so that's gonna be back to
back weeks and I think his value is
going to be right back down to where it
was during his first half stretch of
disappointment but again this isn't the
first half again we have an office has
finally showed some signs of Competency
at quarterback PJ Walker giving us more
good than bad I saw the nine yard first
half last week but how about Baker
Mayfield coming in second half and
actually existing enough to you know
throw two touchdowns and get 150 or so
yards out there so no I don't think the
Panthers are going to be finding you
know they're Geno Smith here anytime
soon but when we have just one wide
receiver getting really all the volume
at this point he doesn't even need
fantastic quarterback play he just needs
to be be okay at points which we have
seen come to fruition so DJ Moore
someone that again I think with no
weather concerns is locked in as a top
20 wide receiver moving forward would
not be surprised at all if you're able
to get him for the price of more so a
wide receiver three that unfortunately
he struggled to reach during the first
half of the season from atla Munford
should I trade DeAndre Hopkins for AJ
Brown my quarterback is Jalen hurts I do
think that's a pretty fair trade
honestly we're looking at the Eagles and
it's a second ranked scoring offense
first the Cardinals who have had a rough
time you know consistently putting up
points on the board albeit they have
gotten a little bit better as of late so
AJ Brown at the end of the day truly won
the best wide receivers in the game and
while I don't think Hopkins is washed I
mean whatever Peds he was on there they
worked my friend you know suspension not
there but the guy looks as good as ever
out there it's more so a testament of
okay I have two wide receivers I expect
to see pretty similar volume I think AJ
Brown is objectively a little bit better
and we know the Eagles offense is better
give me AJ Brown over Dion country
Hopkins for the rest of the season next
up guys one Pittsburgh Steelers certain
wide receiver one now and a bit more
clear of a depth chart with Chase
Claypool out of town you need to go get
Deontay Johnson before it's too late
guys 76 targets to Deontay Johnson this
season zero touchdowns it's brutal it's
the most in the league I mean second
place is Chris Godwin with 65. that said
I had never been more convinced that
Deontay Johnson is a great receiver this
has been an absolutely brutal stretch
for them first we get the Miss trubisky
experience under center for the first
three and a half weeks of the season and
then Kenny Pickett comes in and similar
to what happened to Justin fields in
Chicago last year you have the rookie
not getting first team reps and then
they come out and they don't have
chemistry with the starters what do you
really expect to happen especially when
we see the schedule that Pickett had to
deal with I mean guys comes in at
halftime of a game against the Jets that
as we've seen sauce Gardner company no
joke some of the things they were able
to do against Buffalo last week of all
teams shows you how for real they are so
comes in faces the Jets for the first
half for the second half next week in
Buffalo the next week first the
Buccaneers were able to get a win
unfortunately Pickett got concussed
before he could even put up too good of
numbers in that one and next week was
the first objectively bad past defense
they faced unfortunately the Dolphins
were at home in Miami it will end up
being a fairly rainy and windy Sunday
night Affair so I have a struggle you
know calling that an easy matchup and
finally last week in Philadelphia the
single best pass defense in the in the
league so they've had a buy to get like
Target competition is less than ever I
mean Chase Claypool say what you want
about the guy this really was a
situation where he was second on the
team and targets before getting traded
so look Deontay Johnson clearly in first
I'm not saying Claypool leaving is just
gonna immediately all translate to
deontay's targets I think George Pickens
and Pat fryer myth have a lot of good
chances to get going moving forward as
well but Deontay Remains the clear-cut
number one I mean guys this year it's
the realized production hasn't been
there and I know that's frustrating just
the wide receiver 47 in PPR points per
game remember expected points pure
workload wide receiver nine on the
season that's ahead of guys like Mike
Evans like CD lamb even ahead of guys
like AJ Brown so we're not playing you
know points per Target get points per
carry I understand real life Talent has
to play a role in the fantasy players
that we're going for but with Deontay
Johnson again multiple years of us
seeing with our own two eyes just how
good he could be even with a fairly
washed up version of Ben Roethlisberger
I think this has been a unfortunate
eight-game sample size of the Steelers
having really tough matchups and going
through two new quarterbacks who Deontay
hasn't gotten a chance to Joe with so
far so Deontay Johnson will never be
cheaper this season than he is right now
don't be afraid to go get him for a
stretch run that is going to produce a
top 10 easiest schedule here ahead of
the fantasy playoffs
from at Q13 Jeff Wilson or Gabriel Davis
and the flex so if Josh Allen is out
which he has not been able to practice
this week I would be going with Jeff
Wilson here was able to work ahead of
Raheem moster in his first week and look
I thought it was a possibility down to
stretch but to see him immediately get
ingrained into the offense like that
pretty much the only traded player that
was able to immediately come in say for
TJ Hawkinson and have that full-time
role so Jeff Wilson also impressing with
this ability in the passing game don't
be surprised too if we do see Ray moster
let's face it not exactly the least
injury prone running back we've ever
seen in the NFL God forbid something
happens to be mostert down the stretch
Jeff Wilson's ceiling won't be the roof
but especially for this week over
Gabriel Davis without Josh Allen if Josh
Allen does tough it out I will go with
Gabe Davis guys another wide receiver
who hasn't been great again I'm not
trying to sit here and tell you guys to
go trade you know your entire team for
Tyreek Hill I don't think that's the
best path to winning Fantasy
championships hopefully he is on the
squad so someone that we know is
talented that we know has the chance to
earn a lot of volume down the road and
that we know unfortunately hasn't been
able to get it done to this point it's
going to be number eight overall pick of
the Atlanta Falcons Drake London
again eighth overall pick pretty sure
he's good at football and we have seen
the flashes to show that I mean first
three weeks of the year he was looking
like an absolute bargain where he went
three straight top 36 finishes even uh
spiked with a wide receiver one top 12
finish back in week two it's been a long
time since then though zero touchdowns
zero games and more than 40 receiving
yards since week three why is that going
to change well because we could see the
quarterback situation in Atlanta
potentially changing if Marcus Mariota
keeps on keeping on as what has been one
of the more inaccurate quarterbacks in
the league over the past few weeks here
so I know Kyle Pitts has a minute away
going Drake London hasn't really been
able to get going but again because of
that I think we're going to have an
opportunity here to get the number eight
overall pick someone that in my opinion
just having watched the tape on the guy
throughout the year certainly warranted
that top 10 treatment basically free at
this point I mean Jake London he could
even be on your waiver wire if you're in
a league that's you know not going over
Dynasty and all that so again it's a
player that we know is talented and like
look at Garrett Wilson with the Jets how
brutal that was with Zach Wilson there
for a bit now all of a sudden he started
coming on because Talent will win out
eventually earning those targets will
help so with Drake London again it's
basically just hoping that this is a
talented enough player to eventually
start earning more of those past game
opportunities than he's had from this
point because do we really think that
we're gonna get no more touchdowns you
know not a single game with even 50
receiving Euros from London down the
stretch I do not so it's one of those
situations where no I don't think you
should feel confident starring Drake
London this week or next week but man if
you just look at number one wide
receivers that are top 10 picks that we
have actually seen with our own two eyes
put up some truly awesome plays this
year you're not going to have too many
and Drake London is going to be rather
easily the cheapest one on that list
from at ashbot should I trade Mark
Andrews for a Monroe say brown and Roman
J Stevenson I think so my friend I mean
a Monroe Saint Brown
all the questions we had this year can
he produce you know with a healthy
offense around him we don't really have
to find out anymore and to be fair the
Sun God himself he did have back-to-back
awesome performances to start the year
before we started having to deal with
injuries and that really just has been
the culprit here over the past few weeks
of him not being able to put up the wide
receiver one production that we're
hoping for so just the complete
clear-cut number one pass game option
now in Detroit with Hawkinson in
Minnesota with DeAndre Swift not exactly
being healthy heck even Josh Reynolds
there's alleged number two wide receiver
he's been banged up there's been no sign
that Jamison Williams could be back
anytime soon I just think that getting
into Monroe St Brown for Mark Andrews
You could argue straight up that that's
reasonable enough now we're putting a
top 10 running back rest of the season
with that love that potential deal for
you
guys one more wide receiver before we
get to some extra chat questions here
Philadelphia Eagles wide receiver to
Devonte Smith
again one of those things where who do I
think is gonna be better the rest of the
year AJ Brown yeah he has been better
this year I think he's a better wide
receiver and he'll continue to be better
than Devonte Smith but when we have any
full-time player any truly talented guy
which I think winning the Heisman nearly
having a thousand yards as a rookie and
a run first offense qualifies Devonte
Smith as really talented it's a
situation where look he's not going to
be cheaper now than he is the rest of
the year coming off a buy and then back
to back Duds under 30 yards and again he
is still more weeks than not the number
two pass game option inside of the
second ranked scoring offense in the NFL
so look on the season AJ Brown he's got
the touchdowns he's made the bigger
plays but just in terms of total
receptions AJ Brown has 43. Devonte
Smith has 40. so this really is more so
I think the Eagles wanted to be more of
a 1A more of a 1B situation than a
clear-cut AJ Brown than everyone else so
I know Dallas Goddard is in there and
because of that in an offense that still
runs the ball the top eight rate in the
league we're gonna see some of of these
guys have a little bit of a dud here so
I do think that you know looking into
Devonte moving forward yeah there'll
probably be some down weeks but there
will be for Dallas Goddard and AJ Brown
as well so it's just one of those things
where with ajb Wick Goddard and Devonte
yeah three players in one passing game
there's gonna be some Duds here in
Devonte Smith unfortunately has had a
couple in back to back weeks I don't
expect that to keep on keeping on in the
fantasy playoffs Bears Cowboys Saints
and I would never you know slander
anything about Michael Parsons and
Company but I do think those bears and
Saints match up specifically two
secondaries I do think the Bonte and
Company are going to be awfully
competited fantasy assets for so Devonte
Smith don't be afraid to go buy low on
the guy
all right guys now moving on to your
single favorite part of the show let's
jump in the personalized fantasy advice
presented by State Farm with a personal
price plan is all about creating a price
just for you appreciate you guys tuning
again going through with the main focus
of the show but now it's truly any start
sick questions waivers trades whatever
whatever is on your mind go ahead send
them in and we will try to get to as
many of those as possible so starting
off at Matt Suggs Josh Palmer over DJ
Moore this week yes I am concerned
enough about that weather and to Josh
Palmer's credit back to back games with
double digit targets don't think those
are going anywhere with Keenan Allen and
Mike Williams still very much out of the
picture from at Frosty trade Kenneth
Walker for Justin Jefferson yeah I think
so I mean if you need like wide receiver
and you are obviously already pretty
good at running back that's very
reasonable because guess what it cost
you to get Kenneth Walker either a wafer
wire claim or a pretty late round pick
Justin Jefferson top five so I do think
both guys you know so again rest of the
season I think you get argue that
they're actually pretty close in terms
of just overall players if we had to do
a draft again yeah I think Justin
Jefferson will go ahead of Kenneth
Walker but I'd be hard-pressed to think
cats Walker makes it out of round two so
overall I think Justin Jefferson is the
better player and because you're asking
me this question in the first place I'm
guessing you're already pretty well set
out running back
from at kpat12 sleeper starts for week
10 so Superstar is always a little bit
tricky I will say this though guys if
you have some extra room on your bench I
do think there is still a couple
handcuffed running backs out there that
really could help make a difference down
the stretch specifically Matt breida
saquon Barkley's handcuff also doncho
Hilliard Derrick henries and even samaje
piran Joe mixon's backup so no I don't
think this would be you know a Zeke
Palmer situation where or even Alexander
Madison situation where Hilliard Brita
or samaja piran are immediately going to
be these top 10 you can't you know and
even think about not starting them type
of options but still players in offenses
that we've seen feed the RB The Rock and
we can see sooner rather than later then
breaking into that top 15 God forbidden
injury arise so just something to keep
in mind there for some of those you know
just situations but I guess the sleeper
starts for this week George Pickens with
the Pittsburgh Steelers is someone where
he Goose egged right before the buy and
a tough matchup against the Eagles but
everything thing I said about Deontay
Johnson guys it just adds up to this
being a situation where Deontay George
Pickens and pot fryermuth taking Chase
Claypool out of the equation really does
help condense the passing game that
doesn't have much room to go but up and
I think they have a great chance to do
that based on just how rough their
schedule was over these past four or
five weeks getting used to Kenny Pickett
and how much it lines up down the road
so definitely George Pickens and I would
also say looking at the running back
position don't be afraid to go back the
well immediately with Jeff Wilson I know
last week's uh game came a little bit
out of left field you know fifth round
pick for the guy wasn't necessarily
going to be someone that we're expecting
you know fire up with a bunch of
confidence last week but for him to
really outwork where he moster in his
first game uh with the team and
everything it just goes to show you how
confident Mike McDaniel was bringing
over a player that he had coached before
being in a similar offense like San
Francisco and getting him going early in
Miami so final sleeper you know kind of
start for this week I do think I tied
down Greg Dolce has not been many you
know primary good stuff going on in the
Denver Broncos offense this year I get
it but Greg dulches guys third most
receiving yards ever by a tight end
during their first three NFL regular
season games so Greg Dolce is someone
that took a lot to you know get him to
this place Alberto had it done you know
Eric Thomas and Eric Sauber all these
other guys had to not come in and really
take over and all those things have
really happened so it's a sad day when
you can actually talk about you know
who's going to score more fancy points
between Greg dolches and Courtland
Sutton but I think we have reached that
point so Craig Dolce is someone I would
be starting ahead of guys like Tyler
Higby like Dawson Knox like Mike deseki
Cole commit which hey might have sounded
crazy a couple weeks couple months ago
not So Much Anymore
from adcon uh would you start Gabriel
Davis or Deontay Foreman at the flex
I think ooh form is playing tonight I
would still link Gabriel Davis here I
think there's enough of a chance that
Josh Allen guts this one out and
honestly the one thing that does give me
a little bit more confidence in these
bills pass catchers even if Case Keenum
is going to be under Center we had that
Steelers game where Josh Allen Company
got pulled like at the beginning of the
fourth quarter more or less than Case
Keenum came in for two drives they ran
the ball just one time I mean this is
one of only three offenses in the NFL
that throw the ball more than 70 of
their passes and what Josh Allen's gonna
be out Devin Singletary to get 30
carries like this team is not built to
be that type of offense honestly if they
were going to go that route you would
think Zack Moss would be the guy to kind
of get that work and oh hey he now plays
for the Indianapolis Colts so his
kingdom even if I don't think we'd have
the same sort of touchdown big play
Upside as we will but Josh Allen
understand her obviously still would be
someone I'm expecting to throw the ball
35 40 times potentially and Gabriel
Davis's status as the number two pass
game option a little bit better for me
the problem with Deontay Foreman is the
fact that chubo Hubbard should be out
there tonight splitting things far more
evenly than we've seen over these past
two weeks reform was a much more
recommended play
app pack selling the farm for Nick Chubb
worth it hey man the guy keeps on
keeping on I was talking earlier a
little bit about how just Nick job
someone that I did miss on before the
season and he just keeps on being
literally the best running back in the
NFL while scoring fantasy points above
uh what the expectations should be so
the farm maybe a little bit much but
like a barn you really like you know
that's got that new John Deere tractor
in it maybe that's a little bit more
reasonable because when the Sean Watson
does come back all of a sudden I don't
think Nick Chubb is going to have to be
the same sort of you know Super Saiyan
form that we've seen so far could just
honestly have more regular scoring
opportunities because of how much better
the overall offensive environment will
be with Watson under center from David
uh Goblin versus Seattle or DJ Moore
versus Atlanta gotta go with Chris
Goblin here since Goblin came back in
week four full time guys only Tyree kill
has more Targets in the entire NFL so I
know we're not playing points for Target
we need to we need those to actually
turn into fantasy production at one
point or another but this Seattle
Seahawks defense has been vulnerable to
the slot receivers we saw Rondell Moore
really last week and their previous
matchup be able to sit in those short
zone areas and avoid some of those more
beastly outside cornerbacks that Seattle
has out there so give me Chris Goblin
over DJ Moore I would honestly do this
even if it was good weather in Carolina
but the fact that it is looking so rough
in Charlotte tonight I think this one's
gobbling easily
from at Max Shapiro what should I do
with swift trade start or sit I think
you're better off keeping them right now
everyone else out there sees you know
what the situation is I think he'd be
hard-pressed to get anything close to
Big Time value for the guys so this week
if he enters Sunday without an injury
designation now I think you can actually
start thinking about starting him again
if we do see him going questionable on
the Sunday I just have a hard time
firing them up this week it does seem to
be trending in the right direction
though Dan Campbell even said earlier
this week that he does seem to be doing
better and as he's doing better they're
going to put more workload on his plate
so chill on DeAndre Swift I don't like
selling these guys with their value
couldn't be lower can you start them
this week let's wait and see what that
entry report says all right from at Iggy
start cordarrell Patterson or Jonathan
Taylor oh man we're not exactly sure if
Taylor's gonna be out there but he is
practicing in full on Thursday this is
tough guys if you go to my Twitter at
iheartit's I have and it's been in there
for about 10 years now president of the
Cordero Patterson fan club so so you
know what I got I gotta live up to that
give me Cordero Patterson over Taylor I
think there is enough concern about
Taylor Maybe not playing maybe being
limited that let's take the top 15
running back in a game that should force
the Falcons to run more than ever not
like they really needed a reason to
exactly do that in the first place
from at jakewood ramandre and DeAndre
Hopkins for Stefan Diggs I think that's
a little too much man again like what's
the difference between Stefan Diggs and
DeAndre Hopkins uh really a couple ranks
you know you're ranking Stefan Diggs
wide receiver three maybe wide receiver
four and Hopkins is only going to be a
few spots behind and ramandre again I'm
not going to list the running backs but
seventh most fantasy friendly workload
in the entire NFL among running backs
this year so for me yeah you'd rather
have digs over DeAndre Hopkins so would
I but just giving away someone like
ramandre man if you were able to give
away I don't know like an Antonio Gibson
or you know David Montgomery or like an
rb2 rb3 type to sweeten the deal that's
one thing but now when you're trading
Hopkins and ramondre Stevenson I feel
like you're paying you know like a
dollar fifty for a dollar from at the
z-man Josh Jacobs for Amari Cooper
that's reasonable I think if you are in
a situation where you have a bunch of
good running backs and like Jacobs is
someone who you're already kind of
having to flex in the first place go
ahead and get Cooper because he's
already proven to be an upside receiver
2 with your Kobe percent under Center
and just like we were talking about with
going out there and buying Dave and the
joku once you add to Sean Watson back
into the picture only going to be you
know arrows going up there for Trooper
down the stretch from Assemble video AJ
Brown for Debo and Miles Sanders that's
an interesting one I think it's pretty
fair again make sure this matches your
roster construction fine but if you're
really struggling to get that rb2 you
know one of those zero RB type of
rosters yeah I would take AJ Brown over
Debo Samuel straight up but that
difference isn't huge and I think Miles
Sanders has done enough this year where
we're going to continue to see him get
15 plus touches each and every game even
if it's not going to turn into that
full-time three down rule so AJ Brown
he'll consistently be a top 10 wide
receiver I do think Debo's falling down
a little bit more into that top 15 top
18 range but again that's not too far
off and when you're getting a running
back then I'm guessing there's a lot of
good things for your roster I do think
it's worth it and the final question
from at MCD should I trade Juju for
Khalil Herbert no keep Juju Smith
Schuster as much as we want Khalil
Herbert to happen Dave Montgomery's
there and Dave Montgomery is objectively
better than Herbert in the passing game
and pass blocking that's why the Bears
don't take him off the field they get
the Bears like you know a middle-class
man's version of like the Cowboys more
or less where we have Montgomery and
Zeke these guys that we really wish
would go off the field for their more
efficient backups but guys we're not
running the Bears we're not running the
Cowboys it's not going to change without
an injury so with Juju we have a weekly
top 20 receiver someone that has emerged
as Patrick Patrick Mahomes is number one
wide receiver I don't think trading that
guy for who is honestly more of a
handcuffed running back you know kind of
a low end Flex more weeks than not is
worth it so I want to thank you guys for
all those great questions and for tuning
in with us week 10 we've made it guys
over halfway through the season at this
point and we're not done yet we'll be
back each and every Thursday 5 p.m
eastern time more topics more questions
more goodness so I'm Ian Hardis thanks
again for tuning in to be our fantasy
live until next time take care everybody